Mark Zuckerberg testified in front of
Congress that was that was riveting
not afraid yeah I thought he did a fine
job he was not the most animated no no
yeah it was like watching paint dry and
a saltine cracker
why would someone paint the saltine
cracker I don't know
okay alright anyway yeah it was pretty
interesting to watch these uh you know
these these older senators sometimes ask
him questions about Facebook it was like
grandpa saying oh right what is this and
how does it work why is it still
blinking 12:00 yeah yeah exactly can you
help me with the VCR well it was a big
deal a lot of senators had their
questions today Senator Lindsey Graham
asked Mark Zuckerberg if there was
anything else like Facebook and
Zuckerberg said no yeah and at that
exact moment Tom from MySpace took his
own life
Wow a weird group yeah he committed
suicide
get this hacking of personal information
it's a big deal experts say the majority
of Facebook users had their data
harvested from taking online quizzes yes
yeah
so it's worse than we thought now Russia
knows how stupid we are and then they
know that I'm a Miranda sources say the
FBI raided Michael Cohen's office to
gather information on all the women the
president has had affairs with all of
them yeah
the rate is currently entering its 27th
hour the joke there is that there's a
lot of them
so take as long as 27 hours to
investigate them completely a motorcycle
gang in Canada yes they have them a
motorcycle gang this is a crazy story
but it's true in Canada is attacking
businesses they don't like by giving
them mass one-star reviews online a
motorcycle gang yeah yes through the
fearsome badass biker gang known as
yelps angels
[Applause]
when I was mining I was sure to put the
phone back here after right an Arizona
mom was arrested after her toddler ate
mac and cheese laced with marijuana
the Arizona mom was charged with
impersonating a Florida mom
[Applause]
you